I just wanted to start on the tragic
stabbing attack that we saw in Glasgow
now the man who was shot dead by police
we know was a 28 year old asylum seeker
who came to the United Kingdom six
months ago he'd been staying in a hotel
with around a hundred other asylum
seekers rather than a flat as usual what
lesson should we learn from the attack
well I think first of all Sophie I mean
there's very limited information that I
can share because there's an ongoing
investigation but I think first and
foremost I want to pay tribute to the
police and to the emergency workers the
first responders in the way in which
they handled what happened the incident
and obviously there are individuals that
have been injured we have a police
officer as well who who was injured so
my thoughts are with them and they've
been outstanding absolutely first-class
we have to remember as well though
specifically when it comes to asylum
seeker and accommodation accommodation
has been allocated in this particular
way because of the copic 19 crisis so of
course we constantly review the methods
around asylum the accommodation the
provision the support all of which is in
line with law so back down to the
immigration asylum act from 1999 we
follow all the legislative guidance the
principles we work with public health
England we work with local authorities
obviously we have to work within the
legal framework and everything that we
do in terms of siloam accommodation
housing and support is within that
framework okay now moving on to coping
19 and the economic hits in particular
because we're learning from the papers
this morning that the Prime Minister is
going to be setting out on Tuesday if
you like a plan to build our way back to
health after coronavirus what is the
idea well it's an important plan we are
absolutely keen we've been clear from
day one effectively that you know once
we've moved past the peak of the virus
it was our objective to get society
reopened again and to get Britain moving
again and as you've seen from what is
what's been trailed in some of the
newspapers today this is an ambitious
government a government that wants to
level up a government that wants to
bring social justice
greater economic opportunity better
support for the entire country and
across the country this is in line with
our manifesto commitments many of the
points that we made ruin the general
election so fee which is only six months
ago so as we move out of this awful
awful period of coronavirus this
dreadful disease we want to get Britain
moving again we built we're building now
very much a road to recovery a road map
focusing on infrastructure right now
leveling up across across the country
focused on roads broadband the type of
things have effectively helped to create
jobs but also provide services and
growth the economic growth and
opportunity around the country yeah
things have certainly changed since that
a general election that you mentioned
there and just before your interview we
spoke to Mark Drake for the First
Minister of Wales he was talking about
his concerns about this government's
messaging effectively saying that it was
too positive saying things are going to
get back to normal when actually there's
still such a high prevalence of the
virus among us now I know of course that
you be keen to give good news but he's
got a point hasn't he isn't it early to
talk about the country bouncing forward
as Boris Johnson does in the mellah on
Sunday when people are still dying of
coronavirus when the infection rate
isn't falling as quickly as we hope and
when millions of children is still out
of school
well they're absolutely not some the
government outlines in may in fact the
Prime Minister outlined effectively a
roadmap a roadmap to reopen in our
country reopening society getting
children back to school getting people
back to work but we have to remember
Sophie all of this is within a framework
this isn't a sort this isn't an
overnight announcement that things are
going to switch back to normal tomorrow
we have parent pand this out planned
this in terms of a roadmap over a period
of time we've been working with
businesses in terms of engaging with
them on the right type of guidance in
terms of how we reopen society whether
it's the hospitality sector whether it's
key industries how we support businesses
and getting their staff back to work
you've been part of many of the
discussions you've interviewed people on
your program before about even public
transport people use in public transport
there is a combined and a coherent
approach that this government has taken
and I think it applies across the four
nations the whole of the United Kingdom
it is true that we are all at different
stages of this virus this virus has not
gone away we don't have a vaccine we are
seeing heroic efforts internationally
led by our country as well in terms of
putting resources in to find a vaccine
but we are living with this virus and
because that's the situation we have to
work within the scientific advice the
guidance we have to be very
conscientious about public health we
want to control the spread of this virus
we are working to support industry
working to support the private sector as
well as the public sector to get people
back to work and to get our economy
moving that is absolutely the right
thing to do and on top of that it's fair
to say we've spent over a hundred
billion pounds in supporting the economy
over the last 13 weeks through what has
been a very very difficult and
challenging economic variate I knew give
the impression that this is a road map
that the government's been following a
perfect plan if you like where
everything has happened exactly the time
that it should but if you just look at
some of the individual policies it's you
know hard to escape the view that things
have been changing pretty quickly I mean
airbridges for example something that
we're expecting to hear more about about
whether or not they'll be countries that
the UK can link up with to escape this
two-week warranty when you get back to
the United Kingdom
I mean we didn't do that in the
beginning when other countries were when
we had a relatively low infection rate
and now once it's been introduced three
weeks later we're changing it now well
the point is Sophie you've just made my
point for me all policies have been
under review we work with the science we
don't follow religiously what other
countries are doing around the world
every single country is at a different
stage of this virus we were affected at
a different time compared to other
European countries we respond based on
many file review periods which were
outlined in the roadmap that the Prime
Minister outline back in May we've said
with regards to every policy that
they're always under review that is
absolutely the right approach and the
responsible approach that all
governments any government should be
taken okay Public Health on a precipice
if it's about to come on to that thank
you and I was just going to ask where
the countries will be that we're gonna
have a Burridge's where'd from July well
first of all with regards to the public
health measures at the border when those
measures were brought in they were
brought in to prevent a second wave of
the virus being imported in as we see
rates of the virus drop with other
countries in the world and also as we
see domestic transmission fall it's
right that we look at how we can
facilitate travel and the air corridors
or the travel corridors that I my
colleagues have spoken about in terms of
the countries where this will be
possible there'll be an announcement in
in the next few days ahead the review
point is tomorrow which is what the
government had outlined what we had said
we would do an outlined earlier on in
the month so you'll have to along with
members of the public listen to the
advice see what the government is saying
in terms of the countries that are going
to be opening up with who we're working
with the countries that my colleague the
transport secretary is in dialogue with
right now but of course these measures
won't come in overnight they will take
time because some of this will be down
to negotiation discussions with certain
countries but the principle around
sharing data travel data the locator
form that actually the Home Office has
created to capture a lot of this
information will absolutely still remain
because we have to keep on top of this
disease we need to know where people are
Moo
in this links into track and trace this
links into the testing regime this links
into many of the tools that the
government has developed over the last
13 weeks to keep control of this virus
okay and talking about keeping the virus
that under control we've all seen
pictures in the last week or so of
people gathering in large groups on
beaches in parks celebrate celebrating
Liverpool winning the Premier League as
some people acting irresponsibly well I
think it's important that the public
realized that this virus has not
disappeared at all I've said this many
times Prime Minister has all my
colleagues across government our
scientific advisers have made this point
too we're living with the virus we are
still in a health emergency and a health
and emic now of course as we unlock and
reopen society we're doing that with
very clear measures and parameters
around social distance and but also
hygiene measures as well there are
people designed it's actually on the
question are people acting irresponsibly
when you can see them on beaches and so
on when they're not observing social
distancing people need to follow the
guidance that we have put in place and
that's an irresponsible if they don't in
saying that the public the public need
to think about other people as well in
terms of spreading the virus they
themselves may not know that they could
be a carrier of the virus and they could
be spreading that within the community
and passing that on to other people I
think we all have to take responsibility
we all have to act conscientiously we
have social distancing measures in place
for a reason we've been clear that if
you do go out in the public domain you
know going out is a good thing but you
do that in groups of no more than six
people it is really important that we
continue to follow this guidance I
cannot think of anything worse than us
having another wave of this awful
disease that would then result in more
lockdowns local lockdowns and of course
that means we'll be retreating back
after the big gains that we have made
across the country we don't want to see
that we want to let people get on back
to work what children to go to schools
we want society to reopen but to do that
we have to be responsible which is why
we're
working day-in day-out with businesses
with the public sector and the private
sector with schools with the health
authorities with public health England
to make sure those guidance is the
guidance is followed but also social
distancing remains this week Boris
Johnson warned against people taking too
many liberties with the guidance but
when people have seen the Prime
Minister's chief adviser Dominic
Cummings taking liberties with the
guidance it's not inevitable that
they'll think why should I follow this
to the letter well of course it's not
we've had a tragic number of deaths in
our country because of this horrendous
disease and I think that is the most
sobering fact about coronavirus the way
in which this disease is indiscriminate
it has no bearing the crimes are
specifically about Dominic Cummings and
whether that had an impact on people's
reaction to their lockdown car
well my well quite frankly Sophie my
view is no because that issue has been
and gone and we are still as I've said
living with the disease it's right that
we all act in a responsible and
conscientious way we have guidance and
it's important that we follow that
guidance I think if nothing chaos
throughout the last 13 weeks I and my
colleagues across government have made
that point in fatica Lee because we do
not want a second wave of this disease
the disease has been catastrophic
people have died lives have been lost
we've seen the impact across society and
across families and I think that's an
incredibly sobering thought which is why
again we urge the public not to go out
in mass gatherings not to participate
you know in big groups but to follow the
guidance it's a sensible and responsible
thing to do now as lockdown is eased
it's getting increasingly difficult to
police
we've seen some confrontations with the
police at protests but also of course
that street parties as well john apto
the police federation said the level of
anger hatred and violence being shown
against police officers by some is
disgraceful and said that some people
now see them as fair again are you
expecting more social unrest this summer
than usual in our contingency plans in
place to deal with it well I think first
of all John Apter who heads up the
police Federation has made some very
very poignant points about the level of
forces and the violence that we have
seen in our police officers they are
thoroughly unacceptable and in the
previous year we saw over 30,000
assaults on police officers which is why
I'm committed and we'll be putting in
measures in place to double the sentence
in around assaults on emergency workers
but Sophie you've asked about protests I
mean what we've seen with gatherings
mass gatherings and protests is
unacceptable and the violence that we've
seen against our officers is also
unacceptable
resources are in place and I speak to
the police in leadership near enough
every single day I speak to chief
constables up and down the country it's
my duty and responsibility to make sure
that they are well resourced and well
equipped in light of the fact that we
have seen more gatherings that we've
seen street parties and we are seeing
and have seen over recent weeks more
protest my message is the same I would
urge people not to participate in
gatherings of that nature of protest but
all Saddles I would also add to that if
people do assault police officers they
will feel the full force of the law and
that is absolutely the right approach
that the police will take they will
enforce the law and it is simply
unacceptable to have people gathering in
some of these awful ways that we've been
seeing
okay now I'm keen to ask you about
another story that's been on the front
of lots of newspapers as we've been
covering a lot and Sky News as well
Robert Genrich the housing secretary
under pressure to quit his job or to be
sacked because of a his role approving a
controversial housing project that was
pushed forward by the Conservative Party
donor
Richard Desmond he met him at a
fundraising dinner that you were also at
can you guarantee that Boris Johnson
hasn't had any conversations with
Richard Desmond work whether in person
over the phone or on text or email about
this housing development well I think
Sophie with regards to this particular
development the scheme that says you're
referring to all the correspondents and
all the documentation is out in the
public domain the Secretary of State for
MHC OG robert jared has been very clear
about that he's answered questions in
Parliament he's put
correspondence in the public domain he's
written to the select committee about
the decisions and the correspondence and
the communications over this issue and
the Prime Minister himself says that the
matter is closed the transparency that
has been required around this particular
planning application has been well well
it's been adhere to documentation is in
the in the public domain that's right
and the Secretary of State is follow
follow the rules and the guidance on
that although he published it because he
was forced to the question was also
about the conversations if there if any
has happened between the Prime Minister
and Richard Desmond because some people
may be wondering that the real reason
that Robert generally is in his job
because he's acting as a firewall for
Boris Johnson well I think you know it's
wrong to quote conflate political
contacts and decision-making with a
planning application right now the
Secretary of State has followed the
process and he's put all the
correspondence in the public domain and
of course there are very clear processes
when it comes to planning applications
as all members of parliament themselves
will be aware of in terms of the
processes around decision-making but
also with local authorities as well so I
just don't see that there's anything to
add to this particular story or this
issue processes have been followed
documentation is in the public domain
transparency has been followed and the
matter is closed so can you guarantee
that there has been there hasn't been
any contact between Boris Johnson and
Richard Desmond with regards to this
application Sophie as I've said with
regard to this application all the
communication and the correspondence
around it is in the public domain and
you'll be able to see along with other
members of the public who's been
involved in writing letters
corresponding messaging or even having a
telephone conversations on this
particular issue I'm not okay now a
couple of things just to end on firstly
there's reports that my Samak said well
the head of the civil service could be
removed from his post as early as this
week it's we've been expecting course
this a number tend to try and overhaul
the civil service for some time now and
do you think that it's a good idea to
have some fresh thinking in the role
perhaps an outsider well look I mean
reform of the civil service
you know matter that gets disgusting
government and obviously a big role like
that is subject to the Prime Minister I
think the fact of the matter is right
now this government is focused on
getting on and doing its job delivering
for the country level and I pinned the
way in which we spoke about earlier on
on the economic agenda focused in on
social justice this is the people's
government delivering on the people's
priorities and defectively any reforming
government will be based around the type
of delivery that our prime minister
wants to drive for our great country and
obviously have the right kind of support
around him to deliver that okay now
there's just one final question that I
am quite keen to ask you about while we
have you and because more than 30 Labour
MPs from back Asian and minority ethnic
backgrounds wrote you recently after you
spoke in the House of Commons in the
wake of the black lives matter protests
are talking about your own experience of
racism and in the letter they said that
they were disappointed at the way you
used your heritage and experiences of
racism to Gaslight the very real racism
faced by black people in communities
across the UK do you think that some
people have a particular problem with
you as a VA any woman who is a
conservative well I think clearly in the
case of those Labour MPs they simply do
primarily because they clearly take that
take the stance in the position that I
just don't conform to their their
preconceived idea or stereotypical view
of what an ethnic minority woman should
stand for and represent and in my view
Sophie that in itself is racist so it's
very disappointing and you know I've
made it quite clear I'm not going to
dignify that letter any further